שלום שמי Olivia Lan ואני חוקרת ומרצה ב-IBM Quantum הסרטון הזה מסמן את ההשקה של
סדרה חדשה לגמרי בערוץ היוטיוב של Qiskit ובפלטפורמת הלמידה שלנו שנקראת מחשוב קוונטי
בפרקטיקה בקיצור בסדרה הזאת אני הולכת להראות לכם איך להשתמש במחשב קוונטי שקיים כרגע במלוא
הפוטנציאל שלו יש מיליארדי סרטונים כבר באינטרנט על מחשבים קוונטיים והפוטנציאל העתידי שלהם או על מושגים תיאורטיים
מאחורי חישוב קוונטי שגם הם חשובים לא פחות ראו את הבנת מידע וחישוב קוונטי
בהנחיית John Watrous למשל אבל בקורס הזה אנחנו הולכים להניח שהלומד אולי יודע קצת יותר
ממה שהנחנו בעבר ואנחנו נלך רחוק מאוד מבחינה טכנית וזה בגלל שבמהלך השנה האחרונה ובזמן
ההקלטה הזו זה 2024 ראינו שינוי מעבר פאזה אם תרצו לעידן חדש של
חישוב מחשבים קוונטיים סוף סוף מתקרבים לנקודה שבה הם יכולים להיות שימושיים למרות שניסויים עם
circuit-ים בקנה מידה קטן ומחשבים קוונטיים היו הכרחיים כדי לחנך את הקהילה שלנו איך להשתמש במכונות האלה אף אחד לא הריץ ניסויים
שלא ניתן היה לבצע גם על מחשבים קלאסיים רגילים ישנים אבל נכון להיום נכנסנו לעידן של
תועלת קוונטית ומה זו תועלת אתם אולי שואלים זה שונה מיתרון קוונטי שאפשר להבין אותו כ
נקודה שבה מחשבים קוונטיים עולים בביצועיהם על מחשבים קלאסיים במשימה משמעותית במקום זאת תועלת אומרת
שהם יכולים להתחיל להתחרות זה בזה וזה הצעד הטבעי הבא בהתפתחות
הטכנולוגית IBM פרסמה מאמר שהראה לראשונה בשנה שעברה שאפשר להשתמש במחשב קוונטי כדי
לסמלץ מודל פיזיקלי ולהתחרות בטכניקות סימולציה קלאסיות מתקדמות הוא אפילו הכה את
ניסיונות הכוח הגס ונתן לחוקרים דרך חדשה שהם יכולים להשתמש בה למחקר אז למה כל זה קורה
עכשיו ובכן בחודשים האחרונים IBM הפכה מעבדים קוונטיים של מעל 100 qubit-ים לזמינים באופן רחב אם אתם
כבר משתמשים אולי שמתם לב שהורדנו הרבה מהמעבדים הקטנים שלנו כדי לפנות מקום לשבבים הגדולים יותר והרגשנו שזה ממש
חשוב לעשות כי כמויות מסוימות של qubit-ים עדיין ניתנות לסימולציה קלאסית בלי בעיה אז אין
יתרון אמיתי שאפשר להשיג בשימוש בשבבים האלה אבל ב-100 qubit-ים זה כבר לא המצב אי אפשר
לסמלץ אותם קלאסית חשוב גם לציין שיש את הדברים האלה שנקראים סימולטורים שהם
בעצם תוכנות מחשב והן יכולות לחקות התנהגות מסוימת של מערכות קוונטיות כולל רעש אבל בבקשה
אל תפספסו את העובדה שאמרתי לחקות סימולטורים הם לא מחשבים קוונטיים הם לא יכולים לייצר את התוצאות ש
מחשבים קוונטיים יכולים בקנה מידה הזה אבל הם עדיין חלק חשוב מתהליך הבדיקות שלנו אז זו הייתה תשובה
ארוכה מאוד לשאלה בראש השקופית הזאת מהו מחשוב קוונטי פרקטי בקורס הזה אני הולכת ללמד אתכם על מקרי שימוש ריאליסטיים
פוטנציאליים לקוונטי ועל שיטות העבודה המומלצות להרצה וניסויים על מעבדים בקנה מידה
גדול יותר היום אז למי הקורס הזה מיועד בואו נתחיל בלהגדיר את הרמה
בהתחלה הקורס הזה הוא לכל מי שמטרתו לפתח יישומים חדשים למחשבים קוונטיים רוצה
לדעת איך להגדיל את העבודה הנוכחית שלו או ללמוד איך להשתמש בקוונטי בתהליכי העבודה הקיימים שלו הזכרתי קודם
שהקורס הזה יהיה מאוד מעשי ולא נדון בהיבטים תיאורטיים כמעט בכלל אנחנו
מצפים שתגיעו עם הבנה בסיסית של מהו חישוב קוונטי אבל אם אתם עדיין לא שם אל דאגה פשוט תצפו
בכמה פרקים ראשונים של הקורס של John Watrous ותהיו מוכנים אנחנו גם רוצים לוודא שהצופים יודעים
שזה לא רק קורס לפיזיקאים או אפילו למדעני מחשב שני התחומים האלה באמת
תפסו את מחשוב הקוונטי לעצמם בעשור האחרון בערך אנחנו רוצים לוודא שאחרים שעובדים עם ביג דאטה או
סימולציות כמו מהנדסים כימאים ומדעני חומרים ידעו שהקורס הזה גם בשבילם לסיכום
הקורס הזה מכוון לקהל רחב ואנחנו מקווים שתצטרפו אלינו לכל אורכו עם סיום הקורס הזה
תוכלו להבין איך ליצור ולהריץ עבודה בקנה מידה של תועלת דרך Qiskit Runtime כולל כל תהליך העבודה
תוכלו להבין את הסוגים העיקריים של הפחתת שגיאות וגם להבין תחומי יישום סבירים בטווח הקצר תוכלו גם
לבצע את כל האלגוריתמים האלה ב-Qiskit ולבסוף אנחנו מצפים שתוכלו להבין רעש ואיך להתמודד איתו
אז בואו נתחיל מחשוב קוונטי הוא טכנולוגיה חדשה ומרגשת בשלב מוקדם של פיתוח אבל זה רק
פרק אחד בסיפור של החישוב שחוזר אלפי שנים אחורה אני חושבת שחשוב להבין את
ההקשר הזה כי הוא הופך את מה שאנחנו מנסים לעשות פה לקצת יותר אינטואיטיבי צפוי ופחות
מדע בדיוני מאז ימי קדם אנחנו כבני אדם הוצרכנו לבצע חישובים או
במילים אחרות לעבד מידע לפי כללים ואילוצים מסוימים כדי לאפשר
תקשורת בנייה מסחר מדע וכל ההיבטים האחרים של חיינו פנינו לעולם הפיזי
לעזרה ודרך תגליות גאוניות בנינו מכשירים שיעזרו לנו לחשב לפני זמן רב מכשירים נבנו
מעץ עצם חבלים קשורים והם אחסנו מידע והקלו על חישובים בצורה שונה מאוד ממה שאנחנו עושים
היום מכשירים מכניים שנבנו ממנופים גלגלי שיניים ומכונות אחרות התפתחו משעוני אסטרונומיה מוקדמים ל
מחשבונים למכשירי חישוב מתוחכמים כמו מנתחים דיפרנציאליים שפתרו משוואות באמצעות גלגלים ו
דיסקות מסתובבות אפילו הטכנולוגיה של הכתיבה שיחקה תפקיד חשוב בסיפור בכך שאפשרה לאנשים לבצע
חישובים שלא היו מסוגלים לעשות אחרת כשאנחנו חושבים על מחשבים היום אנחנו נוטים לחשוב על
מחשבים דיגיטליים אלקטרוניים אבל זו למעשה טכנולוגיה די חדשה מחשבים דיגיטליים אלקטרוניים
נבנו לראשונה בשנות ה-40 הכלי המוקדם ביותר הידוע לחישוב הוא החשבונייה השומרית
שמומחים חושבים שהומצאה בבבל ב-2700 עד 2300 לפנה״ס זה ממש
הרבה זמן אבל הגענו להבין יותר ויותר על העולם הטבעי מ-Archimedes ל-Euclid ל-
Einstein הצורך שלנו במשאבי חישוב נוספים התפוצץ היום יש לנו מחשבי-על שהם
בעצם הרבה מחשבים חזקים מאוד שמחוברים במקביל הם אחד הכלים הטובים ביותר שיש לאנושות
לפתרון בעיות קשות אבל עדיין יש שפע של בעיות שאפילו המחשבים העצומים האלה לעולם לא יוכלו
לפתור עוד על זה אחר כך אז הוכחנו שבני אדם משתמשים בפיזיקה ובטבע כדי לעזור לנו לחשב
במשך אלפי שנים וכדי לעזור לנו במסע הבלתי נגמר שלנו לחשב יותר ודברים גדולים יותר אולי אתם כבר
מכירים את חוק מור זה בעצם לא חוק אלא תצפית החלק של החוק הוא קצת
בצחוק לדעתי המספר המקסימלי של טרנזיסטורים במעגל משולב בעצם שבב מחשב
מכפיל את עצמו בערך כל שנתיים במהלך 5 העשורים האחרונים בערך לא רק צפינו בזה אלא גם עשינו שימוש נהדר
בזה עם יותר טרנזיסטורים אנחנו יכולים לבצע חישובים מהירים יותר ורבים יותר זה בעצם מה שאחראי ל
הפיכת מחשבים ליותר ויותר חזקים וקטנים יותר לאורך הזמן אבל יש חדשות רעות חוק מור גוסס
מומחים חלוקים לגבי מתי חוק מור יגיע לסופו הבלתי נמנע אבל חלקם אומרים שזה כבר קרה למרות שאולי לא
בטוחים בדיוק מתי נגיע לגבול אנחנו יודעים שזה בלתי נמנע בסופו של דבר כי חלקים מסוימים של טרנזיסטורים
לא ניתנים להקטנה פיזית יותר אי אפשר לייצר טרנזיסטור שקטן מאטום למשל זה
כמובן לגמרי לא פיזיקלי נשמע מגוחך אבל אלה המגבלות שאנחנו באמת עובדים איתן אז מה
נעשה פשוט נוותר ונגיד הנה זה הכי טוב שאפשר לא בני אדם מעולם לא עשו את זה למזלנו מכניקת
הקוונטים נכנסה לתמונה מכניקת הקוונטים התגלתה בשנות ה-20 ומאז העולם
פשוט אף פעם לא היה אותו דבר ויכולנו לבלות שעות בדיבור על התגליות המהפכניות ש
נעשו אבל זה לא באמת המוקד של הקורס הזה במקום אני רוצה להבהיר שאנחנו יודעים שמכניקת
הקוונטים ומחשוב כבר תואמים אחד לשני הממצאים וההבנות של הטבע
שלמדנו ממכניקת הקוונטים אפשרו בחלקם את המחשבים המודרניים שלנו בלי מכניקת
הקוונטים לא היינו מבינים או כנראה אפילו מצליחים להמציא את הכונן הקשיח מוצק המצב
למשל חישוב קוונטי הוא פשוט הצעד הטבעי הבא באבולוציה הזו
אבל חישוב לא קיים בוואקום מידע דורש מדיום
עיבוד מידע רותם את העולם הפיזי וגם משפיע עליו זה מציב מגבלות על מה שבכלל אפשרי
פיזיקלית אבל הבנת הטבע והמגבלות הפיזיקליות היא בעצם המטרה של הפיזיקה כ
תחום דעת אז במובן מסוים פיזיקה וחישוב תמיד היו שלובים זה בזה Ralph Landauer מדען מחשב ואיש
IBM זיהה לפני עשרות שנים שמידע הוא פיזיקלי במילים אחרות מידע הוא לא ישות
מופשטת אלא קיים רק דרך ייצוג פיזי העיקרון של Landauer מבסס קשר
בין מידע לחוקי התרמודינמיקה אבל למעשה יש הרבה קשרים בין פיזיקה ל
חישוב פיזיקה קלאסית הייתה כל מה שיכולנו לחקור עד לאחרונה אבל עם גילוי מכניקת
הקוונטים אנחנו עכשיו על סף היכולת ליצור דרך חדשה לגמרי לחשב וזה מעולה כי
מחשבים קלאסיים יכולים רק לקרב את מה שבאמת קורה בטבע ובמקרים מסוימים הקירוב הזה מאוד
מוגבל וזה בגלל שממש ממש קשה לגרום למכונות שפועלות לפי חוקי הפיזיקה הקלאסית
לקרב את חוקי פיזיקת הקוונטים והטבע הוא לא קלאסי הוא קוונטי אנלוגיה אחת שעשויה לעזור לכם
להבין היא מנהרת רוח דינמיקת זורמים היא ידועה לשמצה בקושי לסמלץ ולחזות מתמטית
אפילו משהו שגרתי כמו מכונית שנוסעת דרך רוח יצרני מכוניות גילו שזה בעצם
יקר מדי ולא מעשי לנסות לסמלץ את האינטראקציה הפיזיקלית הזאת כשהם עיצבו מכוניות במקום מה
שהם עשו זה ליצור מנהרה ממשית שמנשבת רוח דרכה ופשוט להכניס מכונית למנהרה
ולראות איך היא מתפקדת זה אנלוגי למה שאני מתכוונת כשאני אומרת שמחשבים קלאסיים רק מקרבים
את הטבע בצורה גרועה ולפעמים זה יקר מדי אפילו לנסות שהם יעשו את זה במקום לסמלץ את הרוח
חוקרים פשוט יוצרים אותה מחדש באופן דומה מחשבים קוונטיים לא צריכים לקרב את חוקי הטבע ברמה
המולקולרית כי הם פועלים לפי החוקים האלה באופן מהותי הם לא צריכים לסמלץ כלום הם מחקים את זה ו
אותם קשיים עולים כשאנחנו מסמלצים סוללות או תגובות כימיות מה שמביא אותנו לחלק הבא
שלנו מחשוב קוונטי למה זה טוב אז
למה שבכלל נרצה לחשוב על שילוב מכניקת הקוונטים ומחשוב ובכן כבר יש שפע
של בעיות שהן קשות מדי יקרות חישובית מדי אפילו למחשבי-העל המתקדמים ביותר שלנו לפתור
אולי אלה בעיות שרק חוקרים ממוקדים בהן אבל ההשפעות שלהן יכולות לגעת בכל חלקי
העולם הבעיות האלה שמחשבים קלאסיים נתקעים עליהן הם דברים שאנחנו כחברה הולכים ונהיים יותר ויותר
תלויים בטכנולוגיה בשבילם ובאמת אכפת לנו מהם כמו יעילות סוללות מידול פיננסי ו
אופטימיזציה ואפילו איך לבנות מטוסים טובים יותר אז למה לפנות למחשבים קוונטיים ובכן יש לנו סיבות טובות מאוד
לחשוב שיש כאן הרבה פוטנציאל ואנחנו יכולים לפתוח דלתות לחישוב חדש שכרגע מחוץ להישג יד אפילו
למחשבי-העל החזקים ביותר בתיאוריה אלגוריתמים קוונטיים מסוימים מספקים יתרונות על פני
האלגוריתמים הקלאסיים הטובים ביותר האפשריים ליישומים מסוימים ליישומים אחרים יש ראיות הולכות וגוברות שאפילו
עם קצת רעש ופגמים מחשבים קוונטיים עדיין יכולים לשמש ככלי להתחרות בפתרונות כוח גס
קלאסיים בעצם זה כלי חדש לגמרי ואנחנו רוצים להבין עוד דברים מגניבים שנוכל לעשות איתו אבל אנחנו יכולים
גם להסתכל על הרעיון המקורי של Feynman בשבילם שהוא להשתמש בהם כדי להבין פיזיקה וטבע כשלעצמם
אחרי הכל כבר אמרתי לכם שהטבע הוא קוונטי לא קלאסי והתחום הזה עשיר מרתק ו
בין-תחומי להפליא הוא מפגיש פיזיקה מדעי מחשב עיבוד מידע וכמובן את תחומי היישום הספציפיים ש
אולי מעניינים אותנו אבל בניגוד למחשבים קלאסיים לא לכולם יש מחשב קוונטי מוחבא בכיס
האחורי עד לאחרונה מאוד אם רציתם להתנסות במחשב קוונטי הייתם צריכים לבנות ולתחזק
אחד בעצמכם בדרך כלל במרתף עצוב במעבדה באוניברסיטה או מתקן מחקר ותאמינו לי אני יודעת זה כבר לא
המצב אבל ב-2016 IBM שמה את המעבד הקוונטי הראשון בענן היו בו רק חמישה qubit-ים באותו זמן ו
שיעורי שגיאות די גבוהים אבל זה היה רק לפני 8 שנים ותראו כמה רחוק הגענו אז איפה אנחנו עומדים היום
יש הרבה הקבלות לימים הראשונים מאוד של המחשב המודרני כמו שציינתי זה אתגר
מאוד קשה ורק בתוך 8 השנים האחרונות מחשבים קוונטיים הפכו לזמינים באופן רחב מלבד
לאלה שעבדו במעבדה או מתקן חדשניים אבל בשמונה השנים האלה עשינו התקדמות בכל
המעבדים הקדמיים גדולים בסדרי גודל במספר ה-qubit, ה-gate השתפרו משמעותית, והכנסנו שיטות
לצמצום או מיתון שגיאות שמובנות במערכות הקוונטיות גם בזמן שאנחנו ממשיכים קדימה ליצור
מחשבים קוונטיים עמידים לתקלות עכשיו אתם וכל אחד אחר יכולים להשתמש באחד מהמעבדים הקוונטיים הרבים של IBM Quantum שנמצאים
בענן כמעט כולם הם המערכות הכי חדשות ומתקדמות עם מעל 100
qubit אבל זה לא רק הגודל של המעבדים שחשוב זה רק מדד אחד שאכפת לנו ממנו וזה
הגיוני נכון אם יש לנו יותר qubit זה כמובן עדיף בתנאי שהגדלת מספר ה-qubit
לא פוגעת בביצועים אבל זה לא תמיד המצב אנחנו צריכים יותר qubit באיכות טובה שלא מפריעים
אחד לשני דרך cross talk כשאנחנו לא רוצים שזה יקרה איך ה-qubit מחוברים זה לזה זה גם משהו חשוב לזכור ב-
circuit מוליכים-על זה אתגר להבין איך הכי טוב לחבר פיזית את ה-qubit מדד מאוד חשוב נוסף
הוא נאמנות gate של שני qubit. gate שרצים על qubit בודד לא כל כך רגישים לשגיאות gate של שני qubit הם הרבה
יותר מדאיגים ובדרך כלל אחד המדדים הראשונים שמסתכלים עליהם כדי לראות איך הביצועים משתפרים עם
הזמן gate של שני qubit קריטיים כי הם אחראים ליצירת שזירה בין ה-qubit
שזה אחד מתופעות הפיזיקה שנותנות למחשבים קוונטיים את הכוח שלהם לבסוף אנחנו מחפשים מהירות ויעילות
אנחנו צריכים לוודא שהזמן שמוקדש להרצת תוכנית על השבב הקוונטי מבוצע הכי מהר והכי יעיל
שאפשר אנחנו מתייחסים לשלושת המדדים האלה ביחד בתור קנה מידה איכות ו-
מהירות כולם חיוניים לשיפור ביצועים עכשיו אני רוצה להראות לכם כמה גרפים מהירים כדי לגבות את מה שאמרתי
על איך שהטכנולוגיה עצמה באמת מתפתחת די מהר ספירת ה-qubit עצמה היא הכי קלה
להבנה לדעתי ו-IBM פרסמה מפת דרכים של איפה אנחנו מקווים להיות בשנים הקרובות מבחינת מספר qubit
וגודל מעבד ל-2024 כשאנחנו מצלמים את הסרטון הזה אנחנו בדיוק בכיוון עם המעבדים Heron ו-Condor הבא
איכות הגרף הזה מראה את שיעור השגיאה החציוני של gate שזירה במעבדי IBM Quantum לאורך זמן שימו
לב שזה סקאלה לוגריתמית אז למרות שההתקדמות נראית בערך ליניארית היא בעצם הרבה יותר מהירה מזה
לבסוף יש לנו מהירות הגרף הזה מראה את ההתקדמות של מדד שאנחנו קוראים לו CLOPS שזה קיצור של circuit layer
operations per second וחשוב ש-CLOPS מכמס גם את הזמן שלוקח להריץ circuit וגם את החישוב הקלאסי הנדרש בזמן אמת
ובזמן קרוב לאמת בעצם CLOPS הוא מדד של כמה מהר המעבדים שלנו יכולים להריץ circuit ספציפיים
בסדרה ומשמש כמדד של מהירות מערכת כוללת שמשלב קוונטי וקלאסי
מחשוב כרגע בזמן ההקלטה IBM היא ספקית הענן הקוונטי היחידה שמספקת גישה למכונות עם מעל 100
qubit כמו שהזכרתי לפני כמה שקפים 100 qubit או בערך שם זה המקום שבו סימולציה קלאסית
מתחילה להיכשל לגמרי אז עבודות בקנה מידה גדול שרצות על המכונות האלה בדרך כלל אין להן מקבילה קלאסית זה לא
אפשרי יש כמה ניואנסים וטריקים שאפשר להפעיל כדי לדמות חלקים מסוימים של circuit ואז חלקים
אחרים בנפרד אבל באופן כללי אנחנו יודעים שבערך במספר הזה מחשבים קוונטיים יכולים להתחיל לעשות דברים שמחשבים קלאסיים פשוט לא יכולים אז
IBM החליטה שלתת גישה למכשירים הגדולים האלה זה סופר חשוב לקהילה הרחבה כי כל דבר
שנעשה על מכשירים קטנים יותר ניתן לסימולציה קלאסית ולכן לא יכול להוביל ליתרון קוונטי מכשירי 100 qubit
שיש לנו עכשיו עדיין לא מושלמים והם עדיין רועשים אז אנחנו צריכים להיות חכמים באיך שאנחנו מריצים עבודות ו-
circuit עליהם בצורה נאיבית פשוט לכתוב circuit וללחוץ shift enter כנראה לא יוביל למשהו
מרשים אבל שוב יש טריקים ושיטות עבודה מומלצות שאנחנו יכולים ליישם כדי לסחוט עוד
ביצועים מהמכשירים האלה שבתקווה יוביל ליתרון קוונטי מוקדם יותר גם בזמן שאנחנו ממשיכים
לעבוד ולבנות את המכונות העמידות לתקלות שלנו הגרף הזה מראה את עלות הסימולציה
או כמות הזמן שלוקח לפתור בעיה על מחשבים קלאסיים ומחשבים קוונטיים מצוידים במיתון
שגיאות ותיקון שגיאות אז קו החישוב הקלאסי גדל באופן אקספוננציאלי ככל שהמורכבות של ה-circuit
גדלה עבור circuit פשוטים כאן למטה זה לא משנה אבל ברור שזה רע ככל שהמורכבות גדלה כי זה
הופך את עלות הסימולציה ליקרה מאוד מהר מאוד מיתון שגיאות מתקנה טוב יותר אז כשהמורכבות של ה-
circuit גדלה כאן אנחנו רוצים להיות אנחנו כרגע כאן עם שיטות קלאסיות ושיטות קוונטיות בערך
באותה רמה עבור חלק מהיישומים ותיקון שגיאות עשוי להיות הכי מועדף ומתקנה ממש
יפה אנחנו פשוט עדיין לא שם בינתיים נמשיך להתמקד במיתון שגיאות ולהגיע לאזור
של תועלת קוונטית בהקדם האפשרי ועל ידי שימוש במספר שיטות מיתון שגיאות שנלמד
עליהן בסדרה הזאת אנחנו שואפים למצוא תחומי יישום שיכולים לנצל תועלת קוונטית בקרוב מאוד וזה
באמת הלב של הקורס הזה יש לנו את המכונות האלה אנחנו חושבים שהן מסוגלות לעשות מחקר ממש מעניין
אז איך אנחנו משתמשים בהן בחלק האחרון של הפרק בואו נדבר בקצרה על תחומי יישום עבור
מחשוב קוונטי מעשי יש שלושה ענפים עיקריים שאנחנו הכי מתלהבים לחקור ולמצוא דרכים ליתרון קוונטי
הראשון הוא הדמיית טבע זה קשור להדמיית אינטראקציות מולקולריות או אטומיות וזה
ממש חשוב לתחומים של מדעי החומרים וכימיה ומסיבות שדיברנו עליהן קודם אנחנו חושבים שמחשבים
קוונטיים יהיו הרבה יותר טובים בזה מהמחשבים הקלאסיים הבא הוא חיפוש ו-
אופטימיזציה האלגוריתם המרכזי כאן נקרא QAOA אלגוריתם היברידי קלאסי-קוונטי QAOA משתמש ב-
מחשב קלאסי לאמן ולמצוא פרמטרים אופטימליים עבור circuit קוונטי ובתקווה נוכל לעשות את זה הרבה
יותר יעיל ממה שכל מחשב יכול לבד לבסוף יש לנו מתמטיקה ועיבוד נתונים עם מבנה מחשבים
קוונטיים ממש טובים במציאת מבנה בנתונים מבולגנים שאתם או אני או מחשב רגיל לא הייתם רואים
כלום למידת מכונה קוונטית מבטיחה בתחום הזה ואנחנו שואפים להשתמש בזה למשימות כמו חילוץ
מאפיינים וזיהוי דפוסים זה באמת זמן מאוד מרגש עבור אלה מאיתנו שעובדים
בתחום המחשוב הקוונטי בפעם הראשונה בהיסטוריה אנחנו יכולים להתחיל לחקור אזור של מחשוב שנמצא מעבר
למחשוב קלאסי אלה מכם שצופים עשויים לשחק תפקיד דומה לחלוצים הראשונים של
המחשוב ולהם לא היה שום מושג מה יבוא אחר כך T. J. Watson מ-IBM אפילו אמר את המשפט המפורסם שלדעתו יהיה
שוק לשניים או שלושה מחשבים בלבד וואו כמה הוא טעה אנחנו
כולנו אותם חלוצים ראשונים של המחשוב אבל בתחום החדש הזה של מחשוב קוונטי וקוונטי לעתים קרובות
מוצג בניגוד למחשוב קלאסי כמשהו שונה לחלוטין ממנו ולעתים קרובות בתחרות איתו אבל
המטרה שלי בהרצאת המבוא הזאת הייתה לשכנע אתכם שממבט על אנחנו יכולים לראות את המחשוב
הקוונטי פשוט כפרק הבא בסיפור ארוך של מחשוב זה הטבע שלנו כבני אדם לחפש דרכים חדשות
לחשב ולרתום את הכוח של העולם הטבעי ולהבין מה לעשות איתו ואנחנו עושים את זה כבר
מאות שנים מחשוב קוונטי מציע לנו כלי חדש במאמץ הזה ותלוי בנו לגלות איך אנחנו יכולים למנף
את הכוח שהוא מציע לנו בשיעור הבא בסדרה נדבר קצת יותר על מערכות של 100 qubit
וניתן סקירה כללית של Qiskit ה-SDK התוכנה הקוונטית שלנו ואיך הכי טוב לעבוד עם המכונות האלה כרגע תודה
שצפיתם ונראה אתכם בפעם הבאה